and when we do things that are hard in
the moment what we get is a gradual
increase in dopamine
as we're doing that activity as the
body's trying to protect us from injury
and then those levels remain elevated
even after we've completed that so just
to use a concrete example a
fascinating study where they immersed
adults in an ice cold water bath
measured dopamine serotonin
norepinephrine levels over the course of
the water bath and again saw this
gradual rise in dopamine over the one
hour course and then dopamine levels
remaining
in that heightened place for hours after
they were out of the bath before finally
returning back to tonic baseline levels
does that make sense and that's in
contrast to an intoxicant where you get
that sudden spike right but then the
sudden drop and then the dopamine
deficit state that's the price we pay
but we don't usually see the connection
between those two things and then with
repeated exposure to an intoxicant we
eventually settle out at a new lower
baseline so you when you were talking
about this this see-saw of pain and
pleasure and slow release of dopamine i
thought about the buddha and i thought
about buddhism and the central idea that
life is suffering you know in the
original sanskrit it was the word was
dukkah and that meant
it means not just suffering means
irritant
um
something that makes you miserable
something that's annoying something that
makes you sad it's not just like
suffering in the in the grandest concept
but life is dukkha
and the the way around that and from the
buddhist principles is detachment or
non-attachment from the things of this
world it's because we're clutching we're
grasping we're wanting yes that that is
creating dukkha so really wasn't the
buddha talking about this kind of this
dopamine seesaw
yes the buddha plato and socrates i mean
it's woven throughout theological texts
this is actually just very old wisdom
recycled for the age of neuroscience